well what advice would you give to
students who think that their situation
isn't severe enough to merit talking to
their campus well-being or mental health
services or well-being here at Exeter I
mean what would you say students who
would think that they're in trouble but
they don't think is severe enough I
suppose what I say is why we called the
well-being sensor and not you know kind
of a mental health or you know
depression center is because we cater
for all kind of well-being difficulties
and that might be ranging from sort of
homesickness to a difficulty with family
or with relationships all the way up to
you know mental health difficulties
bereavement and loss you know there's a
lot of different kind of emotional
difficulties that we would work with or
just if people are feeling a bit
stressed and feel like things are
difficult and then they're kind of
struggling to cope with the workload we
can work with all sorts of different
difficulties which is why we're with the
well-being centre so the the types of
support we we have on offer really vary
so it's not necessarily just ongoing
counseling we have workshops which are
just a space to come in and get some
strategies and techniques for how to
manage certain difficulties like example
procrastination perfectionism stress
busting panic attacks sleep things like
that we just have single sessions as
well with practitioners where students
can come in and just see someone for
one-off session just to talk through the
difficulty and get some ideas and ways
of moving forward and some coping
strategies maybe and its really good to
try and use you know use those kinds of
support as early as possible because if
you can get those coping strategies in
place early on then that can kind of
stop the problem from getting more and
more difficult and out of hand so
well-being is one of those kind of
umbrella terms which I suppose is just
used quite generally but well-being at
university we think of well-being as
foes in terms of health and our
and mental health